so you were in a band yes have you
played here yes you really we played
here we mostly played here Sundays at
midnight Sundays at midnight yeah time
time where I'm talking slot what's the
Sunday midnight crab
Sunday midnight crowd are the people
that probably this is the closest place
to get a drink for them maybe one
superfan if we had I was gonna say or
devoted fans or devoted fans from our
very close group of friends that had
nothing better to do on Sunday a support
the scene yep the scene that was us bed
in April i sat down with Anton Yelchin
at the Viper Room to talk about his
punk-rock horror flick green room I
think that's that's that's the
heartbreaking thing to me that I
connected to is when you play music with
your friends you share something even
beyond you just somehow even grow closer
and the fact that all of these these
kids get put in jeopardy is it's pretty
brutal
it's brutal experience
the thing is that there's this kind of
dichotomy between how much fun we were
having in Portland and how much every
well everyone got along how about what a
great group of people was including our
crew and then what would happen when we
started getting to work it was brutal
Anton passed away Sunday morning in a
tragic accident at his Los Angeles home
he was 27 years old
you